[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous part of the lecture we
had recapped the
fundamental idea which led to the
algorithm
of our the familiar algorithm of
minimizing a function a simple function
so we want to export that idea as we had
mentioned at the end of that lecture
to the extremization of
these kinds of integrations which we
were talking about in our
first lecture so we had said
that we would be restricting our
attention to
integrations which would be dependent on
x
y and y dash it is very it is very much
possible to extend our
ideas to integrations which are
dependent on higher order derivatives
but just to keep the algebra
relatively clutter free we are going to
deal with this restrictive
thing now please note that
here the y itself is a function of x
okay so it is as if we are
dealing with a function of functions
this integration here
it is dependent on the choice of the
function
that we are that we are choosing here
okay so it is as if this integration
is a function of
a function so that kind of an entity
is what is referred to as a functional
okay
so this is a function
of functions
so what we say is that
we are now interested in developing the
method for extremization of
functions
so how do we go about doing it as we
mentioned earlier we are going to export
the
same idea that we had done for the
extremization of functions so there we
had
explored the neighborhood of the point x
equal to a
for the minimization in a similar
fashion
here we are going to explore the
neighborhood so to speak
of this function y okay
so let's say that it is at y that we
obtain the actual minimum but we don't
know what y is of course it is a generic
y
we want to explore the neighborhood of y
so what we basically mean by the
neighborhood of y is that
y will have certain characteristics
given a certain problem it will have a
certain nature
uh and as we mentioned in the first
lecture
uh very uh if we if we were to speak
very
mathematically in a mathematically
formal way we would say that there would
be a certain set of criteria
which would let us define a set of
admissible curves
y and we would make our choice from
those from that set of admissible curves
so uh it is in that sense that we are
talking about
the neighborhood of y so we take a
function
which is not exactly y
but uh almost like y with a little bit
of variation here and there
okay so uh the
the function that we choose will be like
this
so the neighborhood of this thing that
we'll denote
by y plus epsilon eta
okay now why this strange way of uh
doing it
you see this epsilon it
takes the responsibility of
uh of uh of capturing
the
the small deviation from this y
so we could have written like this y
plus eta
okay so this eta is the variation on
this y but we want to
really ensure that this variation is
only a little bit of a variation so this
y
ultimately we are going to set it to be
a very
small value and that will actually uh
be a mathematical representation of
uh of the fact that we are trying to
explore
the near neighborhood of this y
okay so let me proceed with it the whole
idea will become clear as we proceed
to the steps okay so
if for y we have this i
then for this y plus epsilon eta
we have this i bar
but this i bar is dependent on x
and on this neighboring curve y plus
epsilon eta
very importantly you note here that this
eta itself is also a function of x
but the epsilon is not a function of x
okay so it's something like this that
you are taking a curve
like this this is our y and then you are
taking maybe
a curve which is
like this or maybe something like this
okay these are the neighboring curves
all right
so i have drawn it in a very arbitrary
fashion here
uh this is my x
and this is my y and uh like
specifically this is my y
and these are my other things the other
curves are the neighboring curves
okay now
uh just like as we had mentioned in the
case of extremization of functions
what we want to ensure is that for
minimization
or minimization and the process will be
exactly the same for
maximization and in general for
extremization for minimization
uh worry about that
on minimization we need to ensure
that i bar
minus i must be greater than 0
because if our answer is indeed the
specific y
then this i must be taking the smallest
value
so no matter what other i bar value
there is it should always be larger than
that y
then that i okay so uh
exactly proceeding with us with those
ideas which we had discussed
in our previous lecture okay
now uh what are the
what are the inside details of which
which we need to take care of uh for
this kind of a thing
okay so
what we'll say is that uh this i bar
okay so writing it properly
so our integrand is f
x y y dash uh
and our i bar is
okay
so now we'll do simply what we need
okay absolutely utilitarian approach
nothing fancy mathematically we'll just
do a minus of these two things
we'll do a minus of these two things and
then we are going to do a taylor
expansion
step by step
okay so we are going to do a tailor
expansion on this
so the first term here is f x
y y dash
plus uh then we have the first order
terms
epsilon
epsilon eta by factorial 1
[Music]
are del f
del y
plus
epsilon eta dash pi
factorial 1 del f del y dash
uh very importantly please note that
here the dependence of f is on
y plus epsilon eta and y dash plus
epsilon eta dash separately
similarly here the dependence of f is on
y
and y dash separately so
generally most of us when we first start
learning this uh
we have a wrong notion that because f
is dependent on y the dependence on y
dash is automatically ensured
that is not so and because that is not
so
because the dependence on y and y dash
need to be
explicitly and separately mentioned it
is as if y
and y dash act like two separate
variables which is why
in the taylor expansion also we have to
treat them separately like this
okay for the next uh
the second order terms the what we have
is
epsilon square eta square by factorial 2
del square f del
y square plus epsilon square
eta dash squared by factorial 2
del square f del
y dash squared and then we have
two terms involving the cross
derivatives uh
what i mean to say is that we have uh
one term which is like del square f del
y del y dash another another term which
is
uh which involves del square f del y
dash
del y and because the order of the
derivatives do not matter
what we end up is with this is this 2
uh epsilon square eta eta dash
it is like epsilon eta times epsilon eta
dash
from the the two separate terms by
factorial 2
del square f del y
del y dash okay
and then for the higher order terms we
represent them
through this order notation where
where we understand that this this
all these terms are of order epsilon
cube
so we close this bracket here this is dx
and then we have this last term
uh integration
x1 to x2 f
x y y dash d x
please note very quickly that this first
term here it cancels with this last term
so that uh what we have here can be
represented
uh in a slightly more convenient
notation by taking this
uh this epsilon term common
so what we end up with here
is epsilon eta del f del y
plus theta dash del
f del y dash
uh plus the epsilon squared terms and
you please note that in each of these
epsilon square terms
we have a half factor common so we take
that out also
uh and what we have inside is
eta squared l squared f
del y square plus eta dash
squared del square f l
pi ta square and then of course we have
this term
uh this twice eta eta dash
uh del square
f del y del y dash
uh so
up and what we are going to do here is
uh we are going to take this order
epsilon cube term outside
not worrying too much about the
integration
okay so uh
as a last step here we can read we can
write this uh
as
so i can write this as
epsilon eta del
del y r plus eta dash
del del y dash whole thing operating
on f
and similarly here half epsilon square
uh this one i will write like
so i'll write this as a perfect square
uh again
in the form of an operator so which is
the square of this
i miss the dx here
okay so usually what is done
is to uh
is to write
this particular thing which is which you
remember that this is nothing but
i bar minus i uh this
is usually written with the notation
that
this first term is like the first
variation of i
okay so this is the usual notation delta
i so
that captures this integration x1 to x2
this entire term with respect to dx
and this second term here that is
written like the second variation
on i
plus of course we have this ordered
epsilon cube term
now uh we are at the same
juncture as we were in the
in the extremization of functions
as we had discussed in the previous
video
so again what we are going to say is
that
epsilon is tending to zero so epsilon is
very small
which means that this term delta i
which is actually dependent on this
epsilon
the first power of epsilon that is going
to dominate
over this term which actually contains
within it
the dependence on epsilon square
okay because
epsilon is very small it is tending to
zero so for example
if epsilon is like something like 0.1
you can understand that
a square of that is even smaller 0.01
now if this dominates over this
okay and uh
going back to our previous argument
where we said
that this first order term
that would be having a variable sign
so also here this delta i term
uh it could have
a variable sign depending on the sign of
epsilon
sorry about that my slide just jumped
head
uh so as i was saying that
uh this delta i since it depends on
epsilon
uh its sine
will be determined by the sine of
epsilon
but we don't want that because if that
were true
then sometimes this term would be
positive and sometimes it would be
negative but we want to ensure
that i bar minus i for our minimization
problem
must always be positive so
since our delta i
is dependent
on epsilon and
its time
is also
given by epsilon
so we have to ensure
that its influence
on i bar minus i
is switched off
and the way that we can do it is
so we required
that delta i must be equal to zero
so there is a little bit of a difference
in the way that we have
written this this condition the delta i
is equal to 0 earlier we had only
isolated the derivative term in the
extremization of functions
but here in extremization of functions
we are saying that the whole term
must be equal to zero but ultimately we
will see that it will
just give us something um something
equivalent to extremization of functions
and further on uh again exporting the
same kind of idea
from the extremization of functions if
we if you want to
really ensure that i bar minus i is
indeed
greater than 0 then and then all that we
have to
ensure after ensuring that delta i is
equal to 0 is to say
that delta square i must be greater than
0
now that is something which we won't
require in our
in most of our discussions of advanced
mechanics of solids so we'll really get
it
for some future discussions for now we
are going to concentrate
on this requirement that delta i the
first
variation of i so to speak so that's
that's how it is conventionally referred
to
the first variation of i that is equal
to zero
we want to focus on it so delta i is
equal to zero
so delta equal to zero basically means
that
we are dealing with this term
epsilon eta you just take a look here
selling eta del f
[Music]
del y plus epsilon eta dash
del f del y dash
dx
x1 to x2 that is equal to 0.
now we'll do a little trick here
and this is a trick which we'll do time
in again
over an entire study of advanced
mechanics of solids and
really whenever we have to use calculus
of variations
even beyond mechanics so we are going to
do a
uh do an integration by parts we are
going to do an integration by parts over
this
okay so
just wait and watch what happens
so uh we take this epsilon del f del y
dash as our first part
and the integrations the integration
will be carried out over the second part
of eta dash and that will give us
data so
this first part that doesn't change
keep it like this
so this is eta
del f del y dash
and then we have minus
so now we are going to do a derivative
over this
epsilon del f del y dash part
d dx of epsilon
del f del y dash
and of course the integration over the
eta dash has been carried out to obtain
a
eta and again integration over this
the benefit of carrying out this
integration by parts now
is that we in in all the terms
involving the integrations we now have
the presence of this eta here
the presence of this eta here instead of
the different things the eta and the eta
dash which was earlier
present now uh
please remember that we are focusing on
the condition
that the first variation of i is equal
to zero within this condition
uh there could be two cases
depending on what how we deal with these
boundary terms
so the first case the first uh
possibility case one
is when uh our
y is such uh the nature of y is such
so what i'm basically saying is that the
admissible curves
are such that the values are actually
specified
at the boundaries x1 and x2
okay so values
of the curve
are specified
at the boundaries
what does that entail that means
that when we are taking a
another choice of our curve like this
the eta should be such that when
x is equal to x 1 eta is equal to 0
and when x is equal to x 2 eta is
also equal to 0 that is what is
basically meant
by this statement that the values of the
curve
are specified at the boundaries so it is
as part of
our characterization of of the curves
that we are dealing with
that will be given okay and this will
have
direct consequence in our development of
our beam theories and our plate theories
uh as far
as the boundary conditions are concerned
you will see when we
go into that so this is a very very
important and subtle part
which you must must appreciate okay so
uh written currently in this abstract
mathematical fashion it may not seem
uh i mean what is going on here i mean
we are just choosing something
arbitrarily
but it's not like that okay so when we
actually connect it
to our theories of beams and plates it
will become much more
evident and clear okay
so here the y plus epsilon eta should be
such
that theta is equal to 0
at x1 and x2
now the moment we write this thing that
eta is equal to 0 at x1 and x 2
you know what happens to these boundary
terms so so this is basically eta
epsilon eta del f del y dash evaluated
at x 2 minus
epsilon eta del f del y dash evaluated
at
x1 so uh both of those terms
they go to zero so therefore
epsilon theta del f del
y dash uh
1 x 2 is basically equal to 0 minus 0
equal to 0.
so all that we end up with is
is just this first term in the second
term and please note that i have
forgotten
to write this equal to 0 here i should
be present
so what we have effectively is
epsilon eta del f
del y minus
d dx of epsilon
epsilon del f l y dash
eta
dx integration x1
x2 equal to 0
okay now uh because
epsilon is a constant so it doesn't
really matter we can take it out of the
integration
but uh
very it's very important to note uh what
happens to this
eta because that is not a constant
it is not a constant but very usefully
eta is arbitrary and because this
statement
this integration must be true or any
arbitrary choice of eta
therefore it follows that this integrand
must be equal to zero okay so
it is very much possible to go into a
far more formal kind of logic
behind showing this but again i'm going
to take up an
uh utility and approach and just and and
just
last i just
say here that since eta is arbitrary
so
the only way
that the zero value of the integration
is possible
zero value of the integration is
possible
is if
l f l y minus
e d x del f del y
dash that is equal to zero so the
integrand itself
uh without the eta that itself is equal
to zero
and this condition okay so this this
condition del
f del y minus e d
x of l f del y dash
this is equal to 0 this is
the famous euler lagrange condition on
the euler lagrange equation
which will use time and again
all through our applications of
calculus of variations in advanced
mechanics of solids
okay so this is just the case one what
about the case two
the case two is where
uh y is not specified
at the boundaries
so we certainly do not require that eta
has to be 0
at x equal to x 1 and x equal to x 2.
so if we go back and take a look at the
condition which we had obtained
here so
we can club these two together but we
really can't set this to equal to zero
okay like uh i mean uh
based on based on any any conditions on
eta but it still remains true that
this integration plus this boundary term
must still be equal to zero
so how do we go about doing it all that
we have to do
is to take up this integration together
set that equal to zero
and take this boundary term and set that
equal to zero
and overall that will ensure that the
whole thing
is equal to zero okay so let me just try
to copy this thing here
okay so what i'll do is
uh i'll club these this integration
terms
so epsilon eta
del f del y minus e d x
exactly like before but of course i have
taken out this epsilon
from this first bracket here
in order to ensure that this result
is indeed equal to zero for arbitrary
choices of eta
what we have to say is that
this will be zero
if so again understand
that eta is very much arbitrary here
okay this will be zero
if
del f del y minus d dx
del f del y dash that is equal to 0 so
individually this
this part of the integrand here is equal
to 0 that will ensure that this
integration is 0
and considering this boundary term
again since this eta is 0 we can't do
anything with it but we can ensure that
this is equal to 0
by ensuring that del f del y dash is
equal to 0.
and again you will see that this rather
mathematically abstract way of thinking
about these equations
will have a direct consequence in terms
of the physically
very much tangible things that we talk
about when talk when we deal with beams
and plates okay and
particularly with reference to how the
boundary conditions emerge
all right so uh as far as the
as the basic uh development of
what we required uh in the calculus of
variations that is done here
okay so the the bottom line here is that
we have arrived at the all important
euler lagrange equation
you please note that this again here is
the euler lagrange equation
and depending on what kind of a case we
are dealing with
uh we we will be happy
just by dealing with the euler lagrange
equation or
we'll have to deal with this case where
we have an extra condition
at the boundaries that del f del y dash
is equal to 0
at let's not forget to get this at x
equal to x 1
and x equal to x 2 okay
now it i mean had we been doing
a more mathematical course involving the
calculus of variations
then certainly we would go about
applying these kinds
of equations directly to some problems
some very classical problems including a
brackets token problem
but right now i will not invest any time
on that as you will see that
we will be constantly running short of
time we'll be chasing
uh to will be kind of a constant
chase to finish our syllabus here so i
unnecessarily i will not uh
invest any time on
applying this thing on the general
mathematical problems
rather as quickly as possible i'll try
to apply these things
to directly what we need in advance
mechanics of solids
on that note let me finish up this
lecture thank you very much